sounds seedy and weird of course it is
but it's still not the strangest thing
happening in Washington right now
tonight we have more on the ongoing saga
of the Trump dossier senators Chuck
Grassley and Lindsey Graham have
launched a probe into former national
security adviser Susan Rice in the very
final minutes of the Obama
administration just after noon on
inauguration day 2017 rice sent herself
an email on the White House computer
system in it she described a meeting
she'd attended just two weeks before on
January 5th at that meeting where
President Obama Vice President Joe Biden
FBI director Jim Comey deputy AG Sally
Yates and Susan Rice herself
according to rice in this email Obama
instructed the officials in the room to
consider withholding national
intelligence from the incoming Trump
administration in case they were
compromised by Russia in other words
almost two months after the presidential
election Barack Obama viewed Trump not
as his democratically elected successor
but is a traitor and Russian spy Obama
viewed himself as someone who somehow
had the right to withhold government
documents from an elected president
that's not the behavior of someone who
believes in democracy and yet that
meeting set the tone for that year and
all subsequent arguments since Democrats
have treated Trump and his election as
illegitimate ever since then and at the
heart of their case against Trump in
this administration is the steel dossier
to this day the dossier is the only
publicly available document that details
alleged collusion with Russia and of
course we've talked a lot about the
dossier on this program but relatively
little about what is in it what does the
dossier actually claim he's any of it
true after more than a year of probing
by politicians and intelligence agencies
and journalists here's the sum total of
what we actually know about the document
that started all of this we know the
dossier was compiled by Christopher
Steele acting as a contractor of fusion
GPS with funds supplied by the Hillary
Clinton campaign and the DNC the dossier
was a form of opposition research
designed to be used again
Trump in the presidential campaign it
was on an intelligence document it was
op oh the dossier claims that Russian
authorities didn't simply collude with
Trump during a 2016 election the charge
you hear a lot about it also claims that
Russian intelligence cultivated Donald
Trump as a kind of asset a kind of one
man sleeper cell for more than five
years you say there's no evidence of
that the dossier also claims the Kremlin
fed the Trump team Intel reports on
Hillary Clinton and other political
opponents for years there's no proof of
that either
it claims Trump was favored by Moscow
with lucrative russian real estate deals
as part of his cultivation as a
political asset that sleeper cell don't
move there either according to the
dossier Trump and Russia were exchanging
intelligence with each other for at
least eight years that the dossier goes
on to describe a clandestine meeting in
Prague between Trump lawyer Michael
Cohen and a Kremlin representative
supposedly that took place in August of
2016 this is one of the very few claims
in the dossier that has been
conclusively checked and it's false Coen
wasn't even outside the US at the time
the meeting supposedly took place in
some the steel dossier is absurd the
closer you read it the more absurd it is
take ten minutes and do so yourself it's
online and as you read it ask yourself
who wouldn't believe something like this
it's so transparently partisan and
unlikely and stupid and flimsy it reads
like a parody of a badly written spy
novel the same time he was firing people
on the apprentice Donald Trump was
working with Vladimir Putin to subvert
America it's hard even to say that with
a straight face it's that stupid and yet
keep in mind and never forget this is
the document the FBI used to justify
spying on American citizens these are
the claims that Democrats in Congress
repeatedly cited as the reason to stop
the normal functioning of government in
order to investigate the administration
this is the famous dossier that even
today progressives in the media are
spending millions in an attempt to
corroborate and it's all a stupid joke
amazingly a lot of people in power fell
for it
congressman Ron de santis is a
Republican representing the state of
Florida and joins this any comes for
thanks coming up good evening
so the meeting that Susan Rice describes
in her email between the president vice
president Sally Yates Comey is really
revealing so Trump was accused of
considering Obama foreign with the
birther stuff but Obama actually turned
out didn't consider Trump foreign a
foreign agent can a sitting president
deny government documents intelligence
to an incoming president I don't see how
you can do that I mean just think about
what Yates was on to at the time with
Michael Flynn ret met with kis lyac the
Russian ambassador that was one of the
reasons why she sent the FBI agents to
Flynn once he got in so they were
creating some type of a boogeyman really
out of Flynn acting like any incoming
nationals that I hear what a president's
authority and legitimacy comes from
voters winning an election that's what
makes you the president so how can one
president say I don't think the next guy
should have this I don't think he's
worthy of this information and it
doesn't yeah I don't well i mean i don't
think i think it's improper to do that
and it's interesting this january 5th
meeting in the Oval with Comey what did
Comey do that very next day that was
when he briefed Trump on the dossier
he went to Trump Tower he showed him the
dossier that eventually got leaked to
CNN and then that allowed the dossier to
get put out into the bloodstream also
during this whole transition time you
have an unprecedented campaign of
leaking classified information designed
to put a cloud over Trump's incoming
presidency so I think Susan Rice has a
lot of questions that she's gonna have
to answer why would you all of a sudden
write as you're leaving the White House
do that email saying Obama said do it by
the book it's just a really odd thing to
do she was trying to create a record and
the question is why did she feel the
need to do that well what's the answer I
think we have to find out the answer I
mean I think that it was clear that by
the time Trump got inaugurated I mean
you had the permanent bureaucracy in the
Obama holdovers I mean they were putting
feeding information to the press on a
daily basis the first two or three
months of his administration was
constant bombshell reports quote-unquote
all based on anonymous sources all based
on former or current US officials and
that really started from the
he got elected all the way until the
appointment of Robert Muller is special
counsel so the dossier itself which is
the center of all this dusty that
BuzzFeed published for public
consumption claims that Trump was being
cultivated by Russian intelligence for
five years prior to becoming president
is there any evidence that's true no
evidence that that's true and you think
about even what they use for Carter page
I mean the idea that the Russian oil
company company was going to give him a
10% stake or 20% stake in a company that
is so big that would have been ten
billion dollars that they were going to
give the Carter page and the FBI used
that to get surveillance so the only
thing that has definitely been
corroborated is that Carter page did
travel to Russia during the campaign he
did that he gave a public speech none of
the other key facts have been
corroborated at all I'm not surprisingly
you know I am i overstating it when I
say as just a normal person reading the
dossier
it seems prima facie absurd but you'd
have to be a [ __ ] to take that at face
value is that was that your reaction to
it yeah that's my reaction I think it's
spectacular and I think it's something
that Comey was actually right about
salacious but unverified and yet they
used it as the basis for spying that's
upsetting a generous man thank you thank
you